I'm doing what uh auntie's do it when
they're at a party like a white aunt
goes to guys the wife is a white girl a
black guys white mother-in-law going to
his house for the first time hey Chris
does your family like me I'm doing it
I'm doing the thing I'm like you guys I
like spicy sauces I love being here
black barbecues are a mood black
Lucentis the story that I love and I
figured Ali Chris you guys have your
fingers on the pulse of white people who
identify as black America version of
blackface I mean Rachel Dolezal I
thought she would have deterred this
from ever happening yeah I don't know
but it start with new faction I guess no
it's crazy
I don't even even read the story I just
saw the picture that I saw the screen
capture loosen I believe the chosen ones
the Jews have said it best it's a lot of
hutzpah yeah to do this which means sack
it takes a lot of swinging hairy sack
the do this it's over black lace
they don't they identify as black you
know what actually chic is gonna doing
that he just came that's merch from the
Michael Blackson show you what you last
night
he supports nobody supports live comedy
the guy does one thing right he supports
live comma and the merch of said
comedian white glamour model Martina big
man headlines for her 32s white slammer
model and black skin glamour initiate
which she obtained through tanning
injections injections injections holy
what the when you're there she
traveled to Kenya to be baptized this
plaque is that doesn't even a thing
never
never here dude it the best part is as
she claimed local clergyman even
declared her to be a true African woman
she exactly what happened is she went up
to a she went up to an African guy he's
like baptize me is black like the one on
the right looks like when sweet Dee does
that everything now I'm gonna ask first
is being black
even though well he'll be funny if she
does you know I'm going back to being
white and it goes hey you cannot change
I went to put fingers screem like they
put the screen got emotional when
someone gave her that chain do you think
she went oh
pink right there she actually looks like
a racist Sambo oh yeah yeah it's like
Jesus
oh man that's crazy singing our issue a
zoo is you ain't up but this you
could see this woman's just clearly
mentally insane from I mean she like
just can also see she's white got like
beach ball tits it was like this isn't
doing it enough let me get some an
injection like who like that like the
breast that'd be like who like I love
big titties no too much like real big
breasts oh yeah like this I don't mind I
don't mind implants and big implants are
cool that's crazy dance treadin like
here's the power of and God is
here let's just sit back and revel in
all of it because she has some
dude looks like a fat used car
dealership owner who's also sitting down
extra McGill black he goes yeah baby I'm
black I got some black guys they say
we're black and walking boy party to me
and my wife what Black's bring us black
food you know the other parts of the
meat the other parts of the
Oh your children will be surgery where
they sewed her cheeks to her teeth what
you talking
this sounds she sounds Scandinavian if
you hear it she's like he talks I hope
he just goes oh yeah what are the ollie
Jesus is British yeah that's what we're
all waiting for this goofy shithead yeah
her Swedish belly Method Man
yeah identifies a black kid just one of
them just one was why now he's gonna
have his hair cornrowed
that's great that's the first dance hey
let me take my finger ill out sorry bro
I watched I was watching tales from the
hood the production was lovely they had
seen which he's in the back forest got
my goal Raju Musa Nell man ago
oh man she was right there
she should have stopped right there with
the massive tits not the huge white
fresh white I mean I look like a Dallas
Dallas Dallas cowgirl cheerleader she's
just stopped right that's what she got
that much she woulda got the baby money
shot right on the left right don't tell
me there's not like a low-level Russian
gangster that won't of course you
all know my lady sure to make her summer
party - that's creep but we said
it goes with Lily has an ex-boyfriend
that her when she was like there
and then she showed back up he's like
yes if you gonna let it get one or two
surgeries like that's the moment where
you like I think it actually to
like Rambo or it's like you think you're
against like a mud wall and then she
just opens her eyes do that would be
funny if you were you're like
what the hell we were talking before you
came in arleigh about like little Kim
she could have stopped that surgery if
she stopped the surgery - uh
notorious ki m - she shoulda stopped at
the second he should have never had
agree she should have put whatever
little breast whatever but the squat
joint was the best she should have never
went past Kim squatting down a town that
was part of the corner I think that's no
surge everybody she's nobody I'm talk
we're talking people were gonna go for
it anyway she people were gonna go for
it no matter what Michael Jackson could
have stopped it thriller
right yeah he was he was burnt but yeah
vitiligo analogue open and the fact that
it wasn't as cool as it is I'm gonna
stop right there
there aren't catalogs telling kids at
school say Sosa is creepy as and
that's just a cartoon version that's not
even a real killer he's gonna stop right
there it was a wrap of that lady's weird
tits she's mentally insane and then just
it was like I'm just gonna how
do I get the most attention possible I
just died my skin in drug adieu down
Widow hey this is Dan Soder and big Jay
oakerson from the bonfire on Comedy
Central radio sirius XM 95 come back
next thursday for a new episode of the
bonfire said the bonfire a lot said my
name I did dude because I love you